When you think about all the things humans
have put their mind to, it’s impressive:
we built and landed robots on Mars to learn
more about space.
We conjured up theories about how the universe
works — and then proved them right.
We sequenced the human genome to paint a complete
picture of our dna. but as for the minds that
made this all possible, we still don’t know
much about how those actually work.
Scientists have been trying to navigate the
mechanics of our large, complicated brains
for hundreds of years.
What would be really helpful is if we had
a map.
And in order to get one of those, we’re
going to need some brave scientists and very
advanced technology.
So how close are we to mapping the human brain?
If we could build a complete map of our brain
and translate it, imagine what we could do:
We think maybe that will give us clues as
to the causes of various forms of mental illness,
learning difficulties, diseases of aging.
And that might better allow us to figure out,
are there treatments?
Or prevent the onset of some of those illnesses.
A map of the brain could even help us understand
other scientific mysteries, like the origins
of consciousness.
Our brain is so powerful that if we better
understood how it worked, we might be able
to create smarter robots and computers.
There is this technology in our brain for
... actually, in the brain of every mammal,
that allow us to behave autonomously.
It is very power-efficient.
A map of the human brain is seen as so valuable
that multiple efforts across the world are
underway to get us there.
Aside from some big projects in the U.S. — we’ll
get to those later — the European commission
is funding 100 universities to create a detailed
computer model of the human brain.
China also announced a project to map the
brain, and so has Japan.
There’s even several private projects focused
on this goal.
So what do we mean when we say a map of the
human brain?
Specifically, we’re talking about creating
something called a “connectome” — a
complete catalog of all the structures in
the brain and how they connect.
We typically think of there being both a structural
and a functional connectome.
So the structural connectome is the white
matter fibers that connect different parts
of the brain or the synapses that connect
neurons.
And we call that structural because there's
a physical synapse there that we can measure
and look at.
We're kind of making more of a roadmap of
connections among brain regions.But there's
also what we call functional connections in
the human brain, which have to do with kind
of coordination and function across brain
regions.
That means identifying parts of the brain
that work together but don’t necessarily
touch.
We don’t have any fully mapped functional
connectomes yet and the only structural connectome
we’ve fully mapped is of “C elegans,”
a transparent nematode about 1 millimeter
in length.
Even though they've been able to do that,
it's still a complex organism.
And there's still a lot of work to be done
to understand how the interactions give rise
to even the relatively simple behaviors that
the C elegans can accomplish.
The connectome of the c. elegans brain identifies
302 neurons.
And if researching and building that connectome
was complicated, now imagine how exponentially
more difficult it is to do the same with humans,
who have somewhere in the region of 100 billion
neurons.
This is probably the first obstacle scientists
have to overcome in mapping our brains — the
sheer size and daunting complexity.
So, they have to start small, and I mean really
small — the samples they are studying are
the size of a grain of sand.
Inside that small grain of sand, there's about
100,000 neurons and form about one billion
connections.
So now, you see our brain is more than a million
times bigger than this grain of sand, so you
can see how much units are compressed in such
a small space.
And the brain is always changing, which makes
it even more difficult to study.
When we're born, the brain grows over the
course of development.
It builds new neurons, we're learning and
interacting with the environment and that's
also shaping brain connections and how different
parts of the brain work together.
but then it also starts to change as we get
older and we move into later in life.
To tackle these challenges, the Obama administration
started the Brain Initiative in 2014, bringing
several scientific institutions together to
understand and treat the human mind.
As part of that coalition, the Allen Institute
is analyzing mouse brain samples to count,
catalog, and connect the many different cell
types — as a foundation for eventually doing
the same for the human brain.
Using electron microscopy, the team imaged
billions of tiny synaptic connections in a
cubic millimeter of mouse neocortex.
Mapping the, the brain, at least at the resolution
that we do it is difficult because many things
have to go right in the series.
Preparing the sample has to be perfect.
Scientists had to section the grain-sized
brain sample into 25,000 pristine slices 40
nanometers wide.
For reference, a strand of hair is five times
as thick as that.
Then those slices were distributed over six
electron microscopes to be photographed.
It took us about five months to take all the
pictures of that millimeter cube.I don't have
the final tally, but there's certainly hundreds
of millions of those.
This type of data gathering took exhaustive,
dedicated work around the clock.
When all the images were collected, researchers
could then segment each single neuron and
create a 3D wiring diagram...step one towards
that complete structural connectome, which
the team estimates will take five years to
finish.
In terms of data storage was about two petabytes
of data.
That’s about 2 million gigabytes from just
a millimeter.
To eventually work with bigger human brain
samples, something about this process will
have to change, as it will eventually be the
largest data set ever collected about anything
in the world.
I think substantial, substantial advances
on sample preparations, sample sectioning.
And above all, the storage of such will be
immense.
Either technology will have to evolve in a
way that such storage is available or our
sampling will have to evolve in ways that
we can compress that, that information that
we want to extract from it.
We’ll also need forms of technology that
aren’t as invasive as this, so we can study
live human brains, too.
And to develop a really robust map, we’re
going to need to work with more than just
1 single brain.
We’ll need to study young brains, old brains,
male brains, female brains.
We collected a pretty interesting and unique
sample of 1200 individuals.
The human connectome project, led by the NIH,
is using non-invasive tools to study human
brains now.
So the main tool we use to start out is an
MRI machine.
If we're looking at the structural connectome,
we typically use something called diffusion
imaging.
It's looking at the diffusion of water along
these white matter connections in the brain.
And if you have a nice strong connection going
in a certain direction between two parts of
the brain, we can measure that.
We do something pretty different though when
we look at the functional connectome in the
human brains.
So we still use an MRI scanner, but we use
a different kind of sequence.
It's looking actually at blood flow in the
brain that we think happens after there has
been neural activity.
So if you're looking at brain activity in
a brain region going up and down over time,
you can say, "Are there other brain regions
that show that same pattern?"
And if the patterns are very similar over
time, we call those functionally connected
brain regions.
So far, the human connectome project has made
a lot of advances in this area of mapping
the brain.
In 2016, they released the most detailed map
of the cerebral cortex to date, discovering
97 new brain regions in addition to confirming
the existence of 83 others.
We understand much more now about how different
brain regions kind of wire up together to
form networks.
We're starting to get a good sense of how
those networks relate to which types of behaviors.
Where I think we still have work to do is
understanding exactly how those contribute
or are changed by the experience of illnesses,
how different kinds of environmental factors
might have an impact.
So this challenge is immense.
It will push our technology and creativity
to their furthest limits; but so did sending
robots to mars, and sequencing the human genome...
and we did all that.
So how close are we to mapping the human brain?
The biggest barriers keeping us from building
a highly detailed human connectome is really
technology.
In my scientific lifetime, the progress
has been exponential.
So I wouldn't be surprised in 10 or 20 years
if we had a sort of dramatic leap in our understanding.
I think we may never have a map of every connection
in the human brain in the sense of understanding
exactly how they interact together to give
rise to exactly all the human behavioral and
cognitive and emotional abilities.
That's a tall order and I'm not entirely convinced
that we will ever be there.
Looking at the shapes of those neurons they
are beautiful.
They make me happy.
We and our collaborators are the first ones
to see such, such, such detail at such scale
on the brain and that's like the, the old
explorers when they arrived at the new continent.
We are, you know, we are mapping this, we
are going into, into a territory where, where
things are new.
For more episodes of How Close Are We, check
out this playlist right here.
Don’t forget to subscribe and come back
to Seeker for more episodes.
Thanks for watching.